LAWRENCE CHANG: Hi, I'm Lawrence
Chang, Senior Product Manager
for App Indexing at Google.
In this session, I'm going to
give you an overview of the App
Indexing API and how to use it.
Now app indexing is a
capability of Google Search that
helps users find and access
content in native apps
just like websites.
For an app developer,
app indexing
provides you with an opportunity
to drive engagement of your app
through Google.
The App Indexing API extends
this opportunity even further.
First, while app
indexing provides you
ways to specify link mappings
through website markup and site
maps, the App Indexing API
provides a third option
that you can use to
specify app links.
In this case, through
apps themselves.
Second, while app indexing
adds app deep links
to search results,
the App Indexing API
adds app deep links to
query autocompletions.
The autocompletions are
personalized and shown
to users based on app
content that they've
engaged with before,
so it can help
users reengage with your app.
To get started with
the App Indexing API,
first your app needs to
support deep linking.
You can follow our guidelines
for how to do this.
Then we recommend you also
follow our general app indexing
guidelines as needed.
This includes connecting
your website to your app.
You can read more about
that in our developer guide.
After you've
completed these steps,
then start thinking about
the App Indexing API.
So let's get into
some more details.
First, you need to add Google
Play services to your app
if you haven't already.
To do this, add a
line to your manifest
file to get the right version
of Google Play services.
Then, if you're
using Android Studio,
you'll also need to add a
dependency in your build file.
Finally, get the latest
version of Google Play services
through the SDK Manager.
Then in your main activity
you import the app index
and app indexing link classes.
Next, you define a
global Google API client
and in onCreate
you instantiate it.
In onStart you
connect your client
and define both the app address
and the corresponding web
address of the page.
Now in this example
I'm showing you
the actual links of strings.
But in reality you would
likely programmatically create
these links with
variables and parameters.
Then, you define the
outbound links on the page,
including both app
and web addresses.
Now once you've defined
your outbound links,
you create app
indexing link objects
by providing the app address,
web address, and the view ID.
Then, you create a list
out of these links.
Next, define a title
for your current page.
This title is what users will
see in the autocompletion UI.
Now you're ready to call the
App Indexing API view method.
You provide as arguments
the Google API client,
the activity, the app link
title, web link, and list
of outbound links
you just created.
Finally, in onStop add a
call to the viewEnd method
and disconnect your client.
So to summarize, if you'd
like to get the most out
of app indexing, you should
start with adding the deep link
support in your app, then
follow our general app indexing
guidelines, and finally,
implement the App Indexing API.
For more information, see
our developer guidelines
right here.
I'm Lawrence Chang.
Thanks for watching.